Sony launched a head-on challenge to Nintendo with its new handheld console on Thursday,...
...coming the same day as its Japanese rival saw a slide in quarterly profit.
The NGP or Next Generation Portable includes an OLED touch panel and 3G wireless connectivity,...
...the first in a portable games device that allows game, movie, and data uploads.
Nintendo next month will start sales of its 3DS handheld,...
...with over four million of the three - dimensional units ready for the first month of sales.
Smartphones and tablets have eaten into the market for portable gaming devices...
...and both Sony and Nintendo desperately need a blockbuster hit.
Nintendo's DS sold nearly a 136 million units through last September...
...while Sony's PSP was less than half that amount, at about 61 million.
A PlayStation phone may also be in the works...
...and industry watchers say a Sony Ericsson event in Barcelona on February 13th...
...may be the setting for its unveiling.
On Thursday, Nintendo reported a 46.5 percent fall in quarterly profit.
Next week, Sony is expected to post a profit fall for the same quarter...
...hit by a struggling TV business.
Dan Sloan, Reuters Tokyo.